okay so during my 1 million subscriber
livestream as short as it was it was
something like maybe 25 minutes wasn't
anything outrageous but I had talked
about how I wanted to begin shifting my
focus for Marvel comics away from
all-new all-different marvel and focus
on some classic stories and we're going
to test the waters here a little bit I
want to do the origin of Gore the god
butcher and the reason why is because
this guy is amazing we did uh the god
butcher storyline as like an episode of
the rundown which was fun but I also
wanted like I've always wanted to do
like an actual like tried and true for
the god butcher or I guess Thor god of
thunder you know the god butcher
storyline explained video like I don't
want to do this for quite a while and
I've been trying to find a way to fit it
in the issue with this is that video /
comic story and is doing Thor god of
thunder there we go he's doing that when
the Thor movie comes out I think and
we're actually going to kind of switch
because what I'm going to do when the
Ford movie comes out is we're going to
start with Thor Ragnarok and then just
work our way all the way up to
Straczynski 's run you know up to this
point to God butcher assuming you guys
care about this and we'll just do this
you know God butcher Run will do like
God Bomb and then we'll do uh was it
last days of Midgard and there's one
more I think it is I think last days of
Midgard is the last part but what it's
going to test the waters and we're going
to experiment and see how you guys
respond to us dealing pot some classic
stories with regards to Thor stuff so
going to God butcher is a pretty cool
character he's pretty cool he's pretty
interesting and he's pretty tragic at
the same time and the reason why is
because of the fact that this was a guy
who basically just ran across the cosmos
killing every single God he found and it
was one of the most interesting stories
to have ever been done with this
character but what this does at least
what this comedy does is it just kind of
goes back to the early days and it
really tells us how Gore ended up from
being know how he went from being just a
regular guy to eventually becoming a
murderer was just killing gods all
across the cosmos and so what we do is
we jump to about 3,000 years in the past
and we actually pick up where this
pretty dark and printing a pretty
sinister environment I mean it's not
dark in terms of you know light or
anything like that but it's a very harsh
environment it's full of all kinds of
predators but people who live on it are
nomads meaning they just travel from one
location to the next simply trying to
make their way and trying to survive in
this instance what is it happening is
the mother of gore is basically killed
by some of the natural beasts just kind
of
around the landscape no monsters or you
know whatever the the natural predators
are uh but this in turn instills in him
a lack of faith in God and the reason
why is because as they make their way
across this planet as they try to reach
their their chosen place you know their
eternal land whatever you want to call
it his wife is of course pregnant with
what seems to be you know their third or
fourth child the issue with this is that
as they're traveling his wife basically
steps on some loose rocks and she falls
to her death and so all this left to him
is for his son but at least for him to
carry a son his oldest child as well as
whether the villagers are left and try
to make their way to their chosen
destination but Gor the god boy sure is
basically just lost faith in God's and
the reason why is because the people
pray day after day they constantly pray
for sustenance they constantly pray for
nourishment you know the son of gore
dies in his arms because he doesn't have
water he doesn't have any food you know
they're basically just living this
really terrible and really crappy life
but the fate of the tribe is what gets
them through they've got their own
religious leaders around spiritual
leaders they've got guys who basically
say look we have to pray to the gods and
if we do then the gods will give us what
we need to survive now some of the Jason
Aaron is doing with this little bit of a
story is he's kind of going back and
forth with things right like he's kind
of bordering on this realm of literal
and metaphorical in the sense that we're
you know these guys basically say look
we kind of have to pray to the gods and
we have to you know beg you they will
give us the things that we need in
reality the gods will not provide them
and gore doesn't even believe they exist
all he does is he just looks around at a
really harsh environment now it's
entirely possible that this planet is
not hospitable which begs the question
how did the people you know how did they
arrive to where they are now you know
how did they evolve this far we're not
given an answer to that the true be
data's crash-landed here and they've
been there for you know several
generations and they're effectively
dying off because they can't live in the
environment there's any number of
reasons why this was the case but for
Gore himself he looks around and says if
the gods really cared about us if the
gods really listened to our prayers and
listened to our hopes we wouldn't be
dying of starvation
we wouldn't be dying of dehydration they
would bless us with water they would
bless us with rain they'd give us some
sign that they actually exist now of
course this in response is meant to
basically be viewed as heresy but it's
also kind of makes sense that people
would respond that way and the reason
why is because what Gore is doing is
effectively taking away their hope the
people that he's walking with the God do
they believe in are the only thing
stands between them and just giving up
is the only thing that stands between
them and just saying yeah there's no
help coming
and then just laying down and die you
know believing if the gods will answer
their prayers if they pray long enough
is the only hope they have that their
lives will get better and that makes
sense you know nobody wants to believe
that there's no light at the end of the
tunnel people want to believe that
there's a better tomorrow on the horizon
that's just the nature of people even if
there isn't even if there's no hope of
getting out of their circumstance people
want to believe that there is now of
course Gore answering this and basically
saying that hope is nonsensical
leads to him being cast out by his own
tribe and so on the verge of dying he
suddenly met by the arrival of two gods
now this is where Jason Aaron also plays
it a little fast and loose because how
these guys are depicted won gold when
black is clearly an allegory to good and
evil that's clearly what it's designed
to be but this also shows this sort of
you know struggle that's been going on
between the two of them for eons and
eons and eons but for those of you guys
who read the unworthy Thor and those of
you guys who read you know where Nick
Fury had basically told Thor Gore was
right
this is really what it's kind of hard
getting down to these gods the other
gods of this planet of this realm or
this region may very well exist but they
probably don't care about the goings-on
of people on the mundane ground you know
who it is kind of living out their
regular lives I mean how many comics
have you seen or Thor rescues a homeless
man or where Thor gives money to a
homeless man or he saves up how many
comics have there been where Thor saves
some little girl who's in an abusive
situation with parents or some guy who's
being beat up by a bully or something
like that you don't see those comics
those comics don't exist
the only comics that you see our College
where Thor is fighting alongside the
Avengers where he's fighting in Asgard
he's going against you know the frost
giant or something like that
it's Jason Aaron hitting at the nature
of the comics of stories that we've seen
and said look maybe it is true you know
if the gods exist then why don't they
care about the small guys why don't they
care about the little guys why do they
just fight amongst themselves with all
their nonsense and that's really what's
being hit at home here with regards to
Gore because one of these gods survives
and begs for help the immediate response
of gore is why would I help you
where were you out when my mom died
where were you at when my wife died
where were you at when all these
different members of these tribes had
died but in truth it would be like
screaming at Thor because a man's wife
was run over by a car could Thor have
really saved her possibly but there's no
guarantee that he could have it's really
just the
and the anger and the emotion and the
pain that Gore has felt over the course
of his life and just experiencing loss
after loss after loss after loss that
all really comes to a head and so
ultimately what is up happening here is
that some of this power Lisa seems to be
that way of this dark God basically
allows itself to be used by Gore and it
actually takes the form of what's called
the necro sword now of course the necro
sword will be a major aspect of his
character going forward in the realm of
you know Thor the god butcher of that
particular story but Gore having this
power basically gives him the ability of
a God the difference is that he doesn't
quite know how to use it yet and that's
the importance is that over the course
of the next several millennia he'll
basically begin to harness his skills
and so what is up happening is that we
actually transition to another realm to
a different universe called Earth one
four four one two fourteen four twelve I
think is what it's called and we
actually pick up you know in the future
of this universe we're basically have
like vollstedt who's normally part of
the Warriors three but it's clearly in
shape and trimmed-down who's being
tortured and then eventually killed by
Gore and he basically keeps kind of
taunting you know Volstagg and so on and
so forth and Volstagg even makes the
claim look if you have the power of a
god and you're going around and you're
killing other gods what do you think
that makes you do you think it makes you
a good guy or do you think it makes you
a bad guy it's basically saying you mean
you have essentially become what it is
that you hate the most now this
particular universe not this situation
but this particular universe is
extremely important and the reason why
is because of the fact that over the
course of God butcher and God Bomb Jason
Aaron will span three different time
periods he'll span in the really the
early days of Thor you know back when he
was younger he'll go in the present day
and then he'll go in the future the
future in this particular universe where
this matters the reason why this is
important is because this is a reality
where Loki destroyed everything on earth
he wiped out all life on Earth all the
superheroes all the humans the whole
nine yards everything is gone Loki
literally killed everybody that's where
things are different that's where it
branches off from that's what makes that
universe different everything else in
you know Thor the god butcher is you
know the past or the main Marvel
Universe or the present day in the main
Marvel Universe this was in the future
of an alternate universe and so that's
one of the cool things about that little
tidbit but anyway guys I figured to be
kind of a cool video to make I thought
to be pretty enjoyable to talk about the
origin of gore the god butcher it's
pretty straightforward is pretty sure
the reason why
is because his character gets a huge
amount of development and for the god
butcher and the actual I'm sorry Thor
god of thunder I keep saying who are the
god richer um he keeps getting he gets a
lot of character development and I
forgot a thunder Volume one and the God
was your storyline really it's the story
that kind of made him so cool art is
amazing by saga rific it looks
absolutely insane but in my mind is
probably the greatest Thor story ever
told like it is it's super cool it's
pretty amazing but anyway guys we're
gonna go ahead and bring this video to
an end if you are new here to comment
explain make sure you guys with the sub
button to become part of the Rob quark
if you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and I will catch you all
later please
[Music]